work in my head
everything you love well at least we're
good
oh and i almost forgot all of the tunes
will be deleted so
[Music]
hi sanika how are you hi i'm great how
are you doing i'm great oh my god i love
your hair i love your i feel love
everything
oh and you're so beautiful oh thank you
i got all dolled up because i'm so
excited to talk to you
oh i'm excited too
you know what like i've seen you in the
walking dead i've seen you in star trek
and now in space jam like
did you see yourself joining all these
major properties and and with any
pressure for you oh my gosh i never in a
million years i would have seen myself
i just i just can't believe it still to
this day i you know i take a look back
and i go really
wow god this is amazing um i i i loved
coming on to this franchise because like
you were saying what i've what i've done
before
it's it's usually you know gritty and
intense and raw and you know even
discovery has a little more buoyancy
than
dead and because there's there's the
hope uh for a better future and
everything that's sort of infused
um and it's um in its identity
but getting still
gritty in it in its own way
and now here here i am doing this
melding of sci-fi and family and i and
i've just never done it before so it was
kind of like having to you know find
finding this brand new pair of shoes
that i've never put on before and having
to put them on and get comfortable but
once i did it was so much fun
i love that you know i watched the movie
and i loved it it was i i just couldn't
stop laughing the whole way
and i just gotta say the movie
just the whole franchise itself it's
it's iconic i don't even need to say
this it's iconic so could you share with
me like how and why you got involved in
the movie i mean
it's beijing exactly it's space jam
and that's why
because you're right it is iconic and
the original is is a classic now and it
was such a big deal in my home
i
loved that movie grew up on that movie
uh essentially
and so
you know being able to be a part of the
sequel and especially the sequel that is
really is really doing it justice in in
my opinion i think it was modernized to
perfection
and i think that it has all those things
that you want that
bring you back to your childhood but it
also has all these things that you can
latch on to in this present day in 2021
um and i think that's what makes me so
excited and proud to bring it to this
new generation because i know that
people today youth and adults will be
able to latch on to it and
it that that is that is so exciting that
is so exciting to me that is so true
um okay so i'm glad you mentioned that
it was a huge thing for people back then
because now
two decades now we have a whole new
movie and it's more than nice and stuff
but what is something brand new and
exciting brought to the table from your
perspective
you know i will say
that there is a lot more
the family itself the james family
has a lot more um
takes up a lot of space in the story in
a good way yes in a in the best way it's
a cornerstone of the story is this
family and their dynamic and how they
operate and how they navigate in this
world and of course it's a successful
family and you have these two leaders
uh co-helming this family
and i i love the character of kamiyah
for that i love that you see just how
integral she is
um and how this family wouldn't be what
it is without her you know which is
often the case right um and so i i think
that that is an element that is explored
um
in a way that we don't see in the
original
that i think is just i think it's just
perfect
i mean unfortunately that's all the time
i have for you today i wish i could hang
out for a long time i wish i could too
thank you thank you and i can't wait for
space jam to come out in cinema so that
every one of us could watch it and enjoy
it thank you so much so much so much
thank you bye-bye it was so lovely to
meet you goodbye
[Music]
you